aujourd'hui rencontre avec une athlète
loir et chérienne qui va s'envoler cet
été pour pékin aux championnats du monde
de marche athlétique c'est la blésoise
émilie menuet qui concilie avec succès
ses études et la compétition de haut
niveau dans une discipline qui reste
quand même confidentiel même si yohann
diniz et ses bons résultats a contribué
à la populariser ces dernières années
allez un petit entraînement en compagnie
de christelle championnat et alain eudes
émilie menuet 23 ans dont plus de 10
consacré à l'athlétisme
le demi fond d'abord la marche ensuite
les bords de loire terrain
d'entraînement privilégié mais pas le
temps de profiter du paysage
la sociétaire de l'agît blanc un membre
de l'équipe de france est en école de
kiné à orléans avec bientôt le diplôme
en poche
tout cela nécessite un minimum
d'organisation
j'ai fait ma première année ma deuxième
année sur deux ans ça m'a permis de
libérer du temps pour m'entraîner
hélas cette troisième année cette année
en 2015 j'ai choisi de la faire en temps
complet rêvée pour que ça soit un petit
peu dur par rapport au temps nécessaire
pour la troisième année d'école mais
j'essaie de bien m'organiser pour
réussir à faire les deux et pour
l'instant ça a bien marché comme tout
champion emilie a connu des hauts et des
bas dans son parcours sportif
à force de travail avec l'entraîneur de
la première heure où mark hughes l'odel
elle a gravi les échelons jusqu'à cette
coupe d'europe en espagne et ce nouveau
record sur 20 km j'ai senti les semaines
avant que j'étais plutôt bien au niveau
des sensations mais il faut trouver les
courses où toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour améliorer son record est là
ça a été cadre que j'étais très content
une heure 32 minutes 20 secondes soit
plus de trois minutes gagnées et des
portes qui s'ouvrent
ça m'ouvre pour l'instant ma première
sélection pour un championnat du monde
en seniors et ensuite ça permettra
d'avoir une petite marche pour les jeux
olympiques de 2016 2016 rio c'est
presque demain
en attendant place aux championnats du
monde le 28 août 12 ans que l'équipe de
france n'avait pas ligne et d'athlètes
sur la marge féminine l'épreuve se
déroule à pékin tout
une stade olympique peut-être un signe
du destin